[Musik]
das loch in der kasse
hier geht's eigentlich ganz gut weil man
kann jetzt schillen und so uns
eigentlich relativ entspannt nur schule
nervt bisschen strenger tour kann man
nicht mehr so ein verfahren weil man
muss leuten jetzt perspektiven geben
also eines jungen leute betrifft es ist
ja nicht so krass und wir beide arbeiten
auch in den ins land haben wir wohnen
ausgeben
meine mutter ist risikogruppen deswegen
passen auf so in diesem ganzen gibt halt
mal bisschen abstand
frankfurt ostring hafenpark und 24 grad
kurz vor ostern wie viel jugend geht
verloren im endlos shutdown erlaubt ist
draußen sein einen anderen haushalt
sport nur wenn man niemanden
der abstand hält braucht keine maske
eigentlich verboten kontaktsport alkohol
und die ganze clique treffen aber was
gilt dann auf der vollen skaterbahn
das hätte ich jetzt auch bisschen
unangenehm dass sie so viele leute ohne
maske sind also normalerweise halten wir
falsch oder zu viert auf hier so eine
gruppe machen sonst nichts ausgeben
deswegen alles gut ich persönlich sehe
mich nicht in lebensgefahr
und meine eltern sind auch irgendwie
nicht so alt dass ihr irgendwie probleme
damit hätten wenn sie infiziert werden
würden
und ich denke ich habe immer an meine
großeltern ist viel gedacht die sind
jetzt alle schon und dadurch mache ich
mir ehrlich gesagt noch weniger sorgen
viel zeit für trink schule nur online
macht pandemie tun das ist ja das kann
ich bestätigen weil da wir haben letztes
jahr arbeit geschrieben und da ich gar
nicht gut zeigen wieso 4,2 oder so es
ist ein abschied zu einer klasse die
saufen jetzt alle hier ja keine ahnung
ich komme mit klar ich mache ich mache
mein ding ich gehe es gelten und ich
treffe mich auch noch ehrlich gesagt mit
ein paar anderen leuten und irgendwie
finde ich es ok so ja also es gibt ich
habe aber natürlich auch freunde die
sich total quasi zurückziehen
100% gruner korrekt geht es auf der
picknickdecke von kiraly und ihren
freundinnen auch nicht zu wie geht es
ihnen in der krise
ja es geht also ich sehe so meine
freunde auch wenn's manchmal nicht ok
ist vielleicht wegen dem regel aber
ansonsten geht es mir eigentlich ganz
gut
also ich denke auch die zeit wo ich so
ganz viel für mich allein hatte hat mich
auch schon verändert aber auch im guten
sinne dass ich sehr viel über mich
reflektiere tag und auch so mehr über
mich erfahren habe also eigentlich bin
ich auch dankbar für das jahr 2020
ich weiß nicht ob meine sexualität dass
ich auch wahrscheinlich auch frauen
stehe deswegen kiraly und emilia
arbeiten im infozentrum ihre dosis haben
sie deshalb schon intus von beyond schon
ein gefühl von der sicherheit dass mein
geimpft ist
und man sollte trotzdem das nicht als
locker nehmen da ist ja nicht
hundertprozentig geschützt wenn wir
schon noch die regeln beachten und so
weiter das jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
aber aber den park oder die linke sowie
ein paar klassen das auf jeden fall
nicht wahr mit dem wetter will man nur
aus und will dass sich nicht entgehen
lassen das vom ordnungsamt ist an diesem
nachmittag niemand unterwegs
die polizei greift erst ein wenn es im
hafenpark handfest eskalieren sollte die
sozialarbeiter peter pressler und muster
verkehrs von der frankfurter sportjugend
sollen es sanft versuchen
man darf nicht immer der polizei und
ordnungsamt im vordergrund stellen
weil das sorgt auch provokation die
marke ist ein großes thema also
eigentlich ist der alkohol hier im
öffentlichen raum verboten wenn die
polizei kommt wir wollen euch nur
aufmerksam machen wir sind keine polizei
die laufen auch nicht mit erhobenen
zeigefinger rung wir wollen euch
aufmerksam machen wenn die polizei das
geht dann nehmen wir euch in alkohol weg
das ist klar und ihr kriegt mir sagte
getragen oder wenn ihr so nah sind dann
sind wir wenigstens maske ob mit oder
ohne hier können sie so lange sitzen wie
sie wollen drüben in offenbach mit
höherer instanz gilt von 95
ausgangssperre
da ich komme aus offenbachs deswegen
muss ich entscheiden ob ich bleibe oder
um 9 zurück
wir probieren einfach ein bisschen und
so gut wie möglich daran zu halten den
rest den rest den nachbarn so überhaupt
und so alle sist ringsherum zu wo sollen
die leute hin
das ist die frage und das hier ist jetzt
nur ein tropfen auf dem heißen stein der
sommer kommt noch
daher würde ich einfach sagen lockert
die ganze geschichte öffnet die türen
für die menschen die sich bewegen wollen
spaß haben wollen
auch wenn es nur zu 50 prozent ist das
ist ein appell an die politik die
vereine überhaupt alle haben bewiesen
dass sie mit dem chor ohne regeln
umgehen können sie haben sie schon lange
seit letzten jahr schon bewiesen wir
alle auch wir haben unsere konzepte
erstellt die sind abgesegnet worden
und trotzdem ist es nicht möglich es ist
nicht möglich über den schatten zu
springen und das hier ist die konsequenz
das muss man einfach sehen
gleichzeitig warnen virologen bei drei
viertel aller infektionen sei unklar wo
sie passieren im freien weniger als drin
die anderthalb meter abstand gelten
natürlich aber auch hier kontrolliert
müssen wenig harmlosem spaß weil wir
können wir so ein bisschen von den
regeln abschalten und so so weil wir
gehen in die schule oder nicht halt
gerade wegen online scanning und zu aber
hier können wir so alle ein bisschen
abschalten einfach und haben so nicht
diesen diese pflichten so sowie in der
bahn eine maske aufziehen oder so
unseres einfach cool
[Musik]
schon bestimmt bestimmt bestimmt also
ich weiß es nicht bei uns habe ich noch
ein paar kein gehörtes jahr jetzt
irgendwie krank wurde so sie wollen im
training bleiben damit nicht auch noch
die muskeln weniger werden wegen corona
für sportler ist es meist so entweder
nehmen die dann extrem zu oder neben
extrem ab dadurch dass man sich nicht
mehr so viel bewegt wie ohne der
pandemie habe ich deutlich
gewichtsverlust erleben können und ja ja
natürlich fehlen ihm zu aber leute die
einen strukturierten ablauf waren das
heißt sie mal die woche trainieren fehlt
dann der bewegungsablauf und dadurch
bekommt man auch keinen hunger kein
abschied also ich habe sehr viel
zugenommen dass auf jeden fall und man
hat es vermisst rauszugehen mit leuten
zu sprechen die nähe von anderen
zusammen zu sitzen einfach die
normalität hat uns vermisst die es nicht
mehr gibt lanckorona jessica kommt öfter
in den frankfurter hafenpark extra aus
mannheim eine stunde autobahn für eine
shisha am main in ihrer stadt ginge es
viel strenger zu man darf ja auch nur
zwei hosen bei uns unterwegs sein
ja das ist ja ein ganz deutschland
jährlich auch in frankfurt das wusste
ich zum beispiel nicht
ja aber ansonsten ja bei uns drüben sehr
streng aber ganz schön die aufgabe alle
draußen auf der wiese also das sieht in
meinem tat genauso ist wie hier
aber hier ist der aufenthalt schöner
mehr oder weniger ging hier jedem was
verloren im jahr eins der pandemie
und was kommt da noch härter lockdown
ausgangssperren überall ausgerechnet
wenn der frühling beginnt illusionen
über ein schnelles ende der ausnahme
zeit macht sich hier kaum einer
[Musik]
ich informiere mich jeden tag und ich
bin ehrlich gesagt relativ mehr toll
stunde politik ist ich war niemals ein
regierungsgegner krone gegangen ich habe
mich immer alles gehalten aber langsam
die impfkampagne läuft so schleppend man
jeden tag kommen unterschiedliche
informationen man ist einfach momentan
ein bisschen man fühlt sich ein bisschen
hilflos
was genau los einfach los komplett los
langsam geht es wirklich nicht mehr ich
wohne halt auch alleine hier in
frankfurt und dann niemanden irgendwie
zu sehen oder die ganze zeit in der
wohnung zu sitzen im home-office usw
dann ist es schon schwierig deswegen bin
ich immer mal wieder froh wenn man sich
mit freunden treffen kann und ich wäre
echt lorenz langsamer zu ende ist ja ab
juni hoffe ich dass ich das alles ein
bisschen beruhigen wird wieder steigen
könnten ja ich glaube schon
ich bin positiv noch so können auch
sophia chantal und klarer nur auf
bessere zeiten
kurz nachdem sie zusammen packen gegen
halb neun
schaut doch noch die polizei vorbei im
schritttempo ohne auszusteigen umrunden
sie den hafen tag scheinbar genauso lost
im shutdown wie die jugend im
frankfurter ostend und überall
[Musik]